Any technique that we can come up with
that makes it interesting for us is
actually beneficial for our language
learning because it keeps us engaged.
Hi, Steve Kaufmann here again,
and today I wanna talk about a new
approach to working with your language
content when you are in the plateau.
Now, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
Now many of you may remember when
I talked about the hockey stick.
Okay.
And the story there is that
when we start in the language,
we have a very steep climb.
But it's kind of satisfying because
we're seeing, oh, maybe this way you
can see the different colors, we're
encountering high frequency words quite
often and so it's easier to learn them
because they they're high frequency.
They show up more often, but once we sort
of turn the corner here, and we're on
this long road, this shaft of the hockey
stick, we're going from essentially
A2 or B1 and we wanna reach B2.
B2 is that comfortable spot
where you can understand
movies, you still make mistakes.
There's still gaps in what you
under in your comprehension, but
you're, you're kind of launched
you're on your own, but here...
right now in my Persian,
I'm be in between that.
Okay.
So I've, I've developed a new
technique that I wanna share with you.
It might be helpful for you
in your language learning.
So what I do is I go to my normal source
of podcasts in Farsi, which is  Radio
Farad, which is, you know, Radio Free
Europe, Persian language edition, and
every day there are a number of podcasts
talking about the news in Iran, the news
in the Middle East, the news in the world.
And it has a lot of good vocabulary
for things that I'm interested in.
So I download this podcast.
I get a transcript on Happy Scribe.
I importthe MP3 file and
the transcripts into LingQ.
So now I have a lesson it's
30 minutes of audio and the
corresponding amount of text.
Now because it's written in the Arabic
script it actually takes me a long time
to read, takes me 30 minutes to listen.
It takes me maybe an hour and a
half to read through this thing.
I'm at the point now where
I know most of the words.
So it's of course, good to read
again, develop better fluency at
reading, but it also slows me down.
So what I find myself more and more
doing, I may start reading the whole
thing and then perhaps, because I'm
impatient by nature I start jumping.
So I jump from yellow word to yellow word.
In other words, the yellow words
are words that I have previously met
that I have looked up that I have a
meaning for, but they're not yet known.
In fact, some of them, they, that I
might just have met are almost like new
words to me except they're no longer
blue because I've met them before.
So I look them up again
and again and again.
So what I tend to do now is I skip
from yellow word to yellow word.
There's the occasional blue word so I
look that word up, it becomes yellow.
And I go through my lesson that way
and I can go through a 30 minute,
you know, audio file quite quickly.
And I'm focusing in on the
words that I don't yet know.
To a large extent are the words that I
didn't understand when I was listening.
Now, there will be words that
I have made known, and I hear
them and I don't recognize them.
So nothing is perfect
in language learning.
However, it is enabling me to focus in
on words that are on my sort of saved
LingQs list, but are not yet known.
And I have like, I don't know,
27,000 saved links in Persian.
I have only 10,000 known words.
I wanna move that known word
number up to 15 or 20,000.
If I'm at that level, I think I will
be able to understand a lot more
and eventually to speak more easily.
So I just jump from the yellow word to the
next yellow word, to the next yellow word.
And I'm finding that quite effective.
One advantage is if I'm in a, a lesson
on economics, then certain economic
terms will show up fairly often.
So if I'm jumping from term to term
to term, In a lesson on say economics
or, uh, teachers strike or whatever
might be happening I tend to come
up with the same word that teachers
union or hunger strike or whatever.
So I'm actually encountering
these words fairly often.
I'm also then able to go and listen
again and see if I don't understand
more and which I typically do.
So I, I get a sense of satisfaction
that I've gone through this lesson.
Uh, and what's more uh, up on, you
know, until I started doing this, I
found it difficult to keep up with my
listening because, uh, at Radio Farda
they have their, you know, uh, ..., they
have their ..., they have their midday
podcast, they have a number of these.
And I wanna process more of the language,
listen to the more of the language
quickly, go through it, to pick out
the words that I didn't understand,
perhaps move some of them to known.
And this, the technique that I'm
using, I would call it sort of speed
learning when you're in the plateau.
So it's also more enjoyable because
it sometimes can be tiring to continue
to read essentially the same words
that you know, and then struggle with
the words that you don't yet know.
Whereas this way I'm able to focus in.
The interesting thing is if I try
to deal with these yellow words
in a list which I sometimes do.
I might look at them as a list, say
for that lesson before I go skipping.
Uh, but if I look at them in a sort of
list in the vocabulary section, which
I also sometimes do, uh, it's not,
it's more devoid of context, at least
when I'm skipping through the lesson.
I can always look for additional context
to the left or to the right of the
word, that yellow word that I landed on.
So it's a little more meaningful
than just going through a list.
So I don't know if that's helpful to
helpful to you, but I just thought I
would share with you my latest technique.
And I admit that I sometimes move from one
new technique to another new technique.
I tend to blow a bit hot and cold, which
isn't a bad thing because I think in our
language learning variety is important.
Variety is important to keep it
interesting and anything, any
technique that we can come up with
that makes it interesting for us is
actually beneficial for our language
learning because it keeps us engaged.
So on that subject, I wanna leave a
couple of videos, one about listening
and one about reading, but I do
consider both forms of consuming
input to be very much linked.
And there may be other techniques that
you out there can come up with that
enable us to combine our listening
activities with our reading activities.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.